welcome to in these cleats we are a show
that is obsessed with women's soccer and
the World Cup starts tomorrow I'm
definitely going to be texting Ali Riley
saying like she's not smiling enough you
heard it here first Paige Nielsen tells
women to smile more
I think that's what the men want yeah
special guest here for you today US
Women's National Team goalkeeper Aubry
Kingsbury you have a twin and you're
both goalkeepers my twin sister Amber
was persuaded to be a full-time
goalkeeper by one Dairy Queen Blizzard
oh it does it took
my nickname back in the day was muscle
butt who gave that nickname to you
probably people that shouldn't have yeah
okay let's meet Lauren we're going to
make her a soccer fan we're so close to
getting the goal man this is like the
worst type of edging and damn oh I think
it's just gay enough go to in these
cleats.com for more information